hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play and okay
someone gave me a hint on what to do and
I should have realized it before because
heap of bundles leaves I should have
realized that I need to cut cut the cut
the leaves and I've got five leaves for
five paintings okay so that's what I
gotta do oh they're all different colors
so I got to figure out which painting
goes to which lead golden okay was that
bright or did he just put that there oh
wait was he saying
a bronze leaf seems to be natural color
okay all right I'm just putting them
right there I'm not really doing
anything special I don't see a specific
order than it needs to go in so I'm just
gonna guess that what I'm doing is right
okay okay okay
okay
righty-ho right
taeho sir something's not right
oh crap I need some more clue I need
some more clue okay so obviously I'm
wrong I need to really look at these
paintings in figure it out there's got
to be some okay the eye is the Sun
that's probably golden one gold or
something that's probably gold the eye
is the moon
that's probably silvery yeah that's the
Sun again damn it
alright maybe not the eye is face I
don't know it's hard to tell there okay
did I get them all
okay so I've only got one gold one one
white LUN not one bronze one so this it
looks like the eye is Sun there but the
eye is definitely the moon there so
let's put the silvery or the silver a
leaf or there okay and the other one I'm
pretty sure was like a Sun bursting
through the clouds so I would think that
would be gold
No
what okay I'm gonna assume the Sun is
the cloud here time I put white okay oh
boy I don't know I don't know this is in
the woods so maybe it's like actual leaf
color I don't know
bronze sure I don't know oh oh I get the
willies every time I go in this room
because they keep expecting something to
pop out because that's definitely the
Sun so let's try this this looks like I
know damn it okay let me try switching
this one with the with the bronze one oh
man I've got the worst feelings
we find black here okay okay
something's not right okay um let me see
this again let me just take them all
again cuz I'm gonna I'm gonna examine
each leaf because maybe there's a clue
in the leaves themselves maybe the white
is the moon and the silver is clouds I
don't know I'm like thoroughly freaked
out at the moment I know okay something
wrong okay so if I look at each of these
completely black leaf difficult
determine where this came from such an
unusual color for foliage as white as
milk doesn't help me these don't help me
it doesn't look gilded okay I'm almost
positive that I'm right that the gold
one goes to the Sun one happy faces
color the eyes shifted I know I know the
color of the night shift it okay for
that one what is going on here what how
can I get clues to a color okay I'm
gonna try the white as being one this
time or maybe the reason it hit me no I
didn't even place the leaf yet for this
and this one I don't know this looks
like a pretty dark painting so maybe
that means like black I don't know I
don't know I don't know I'm just gonna
have to probably go through process of
elimination damn it ah freaking frack I
need some more clue you know kidding I
need more clue
oh oh here we go it's right here the
death was black okay the death was black
it's right there oh it's right in front
of my face
give me that gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme oh it's right in front of my face
ahh I'm an idiot I'm an idiot
I'm an idiot guys you you probably
really dealing at your screen ah goddamn
ups all right okay here we go
I got this I got this I'm an idiot
the death was black so okay
go alright the death was black the
hatred bronze the happiness golden so
the happiness here is golden okay so
this actually was right
happiness was golden the hatred they all
look very angry hatred bronzed
[Music]
hatred bronze okay I was actually I
might have actually been closed so we're
not done that hatred was brought they
looked pretty angry okay death oh this
is the day
stop that the sole lie was wouldn't they
happen to school nature drawn to death
black okay that's death maybe this is
actually black let's try that at least
something is new
okay and that means the solitude was
silvery at the soul lie was white
solitude silvery at the soul lie was
white okay that guy's alone it's still a
lot of death I don't know maybe try this
for solitude nah this can't be right
I can't be right something's not right
okay I must have gotten the death one
wrong cuz this looks like the death one
has a lot of death solitude was silvery
death was black hatred bronze Happiness
was golden this looks like solemn faces
death
this is either solitude or the soul lie
okay this looks like death death was
black and solitude was silvery the house
bump the house might represent solid
okay unlocking sound oh lordy loo
I'll give me out of here give me out of
you oh what's in there oh oh it's a
lantern [ __ ] me okay woah woah woah woah
woah woah woah woah light it light it
light it light it turn it off please
is it oh come on
unable to lay with us a moral there's
like total darkness there that oil it is
okay
[Music]
huh
still so damn dark over here ah kid
looks as though he's making an offer to
me a little eye on the baby
man that is a weird banging the weird
paying man as a weird painting Oh was
that lots of fertility statue oh no oh
no oh no I'm okay
so what do we got going on here I don't
see anything on the floor on the ceiling
that looks like it aha plant food the
hell do I do with plant food seriously
what do I do with plant food I don't
have any more leaves to put on that what
is ruinous would have brought this here
interesting question okay so you slide
like it right on that
I can't use it can't take it okay
assuming there's nothing left on that
all right the only thing in here was
plant food all right oh oh oh no no come
on it's a plant these food was concerned
about his well-being why is it glowing
oh it's a light bleeding through maybe I
can pick up these leaves again they're
no used to be anymore okay oh oh man
it's just this is the best kind of
horror there is nothing's happening to
me yet my mind is making up all the all
the scares for me
okay doesn't look like anything cuz I
keep feeling it like somebody's just
gonna pop up by me and it's like
creeping me out it's freaking me out man
you're freaking me out okay let's see
anything else in here
maybe I could turn out this lamp somehow
douse it no way okay oh man okay all
right so now what oh man what just tell
me what I gotta do oh oh so I got plant
food maybe plant food in the water that
bug is stupid if I stupid
this only allowed me to see the truth so
this isn't wait maybe maybe I cut open
the plane food there's something in it
no okay all right oh man I'm making slow
but steady progress in this game so I
gotta cut it here thank you guys so much
for watching and as always see you in
the next part
bye bye